- [Narrator] And as they
approached the finish line.
- Two, three, four.
- [Narrator] It seemed as if the cast
and crew were having
the time of their lives.
(record scratching)
Weren't they?
- We have to shoot the finale.
- The night before we were shooting.
- They sent us another
paper bag full of cassettes.
- All original songs
that had been submitted.
- [Narrator] Jimmy had delivered
on the old classic songs,
but he was cutting
the original finale
song they needed close.
- And we were taking these
cassettes out of the bag
one at a time and listening to them.
Pop, take it out, next one.
The last cassette.
- It starts off (vocalizes).
- And I stopped it and I said,
"Miranda, is it because it's
the last friggin' cassette
"or is there something in
the lyric of this song?"
And she said.
- "Put it in."
- "Put it on again."
♪ Now I'm ♪
♪ Having the time of my life ♪
- Oh my god, maybe that's the song.
- Well, that was it.
- [Narrator] And for the
next three days straight
it was all they heard.
A cast of hundreds, endless dancing,
working late into the night.
- We were doing it into,
like, three in the morning.
- [Woman] Hi, Mom.
- Hi, Mom.
- [Narrator] And they
also filmed that line
that might well be more
famous than the movie itself.
- Nobody puts Baby in a corner.
- What a ridiculous line.
- There was no corner we were shooting in.
There's kind of a pillar.
- [Narrator] But the line's
author must surely have seen
that immortal phrase as she penned
that unforgettable dialogue.
- I think it's really something
that I was not deeply committed to.
I don't think it's a great phrase.
- [Narrator] Okay then, how 'bout the guy
who acted it into a great phrase?
- He thought it was the
stupidest line in the world
and I think he was right.
- Years later he said,
"Boy, was I wrong about that one!"
- [Narrator] But it wasn't just
a painful line Patrick had to endure.
The finale had some of
the most technically difficult
dancing in the movie.
- When he jumps off the
stage and does that tour.
- He really busted up his knee.
- [Director] Here we go.
One more time, please.
- He had to leap off that
stage 12 or 13, 14 times.
- [Director] Here we go.
- He was hurting.
- [Director] Once again.
- And he came over to me
and he whispered in my ear,
"I've got one more in me.
"Please make sure all the cameras get it."
Then I said to Emil, "We
have to get it right now.
"Patrick's suffering.
"He wants to do this but we
have to get it at this moment."
- Let's do one more shot.
- I'll stand by.
- [Director] Three, two, and playback.
(dramatic music)
Cut!
(cheering)
- He had one more in him.
He was that kind of a person.
He suffered for his art.
- [Narrator] But Patrick wasn't done yet.
The finale wouldn't be complete
without one iconic moment and
one last show of strength.
(dramatic music)
(chattering)
(cheering)
After 45 days, those splendid words.
- [Director] That's a wrap.
(cheering)